إنه موسم الفرح الذي يمكن أن يجلب
الحزن أيضًا إذا كنت حزينًا على خسارة
قد تكون تضحك وتعاني من الفرح
وفي غضون ثوانٍ تشعر بموجة عميقة من
الحزن وتبكي
ولا حرج عليك في
موسم الأعياد هذا ، تقول المعالج جودي بومشتاين.
لممارسة التعاطف مع الذات ، تخلص
من هذه الفكرة القائلة بأن الأمور يجب أن تكون
بطريقة معينة لأنه في بعض الأحيان
بالإضافة إلى حزننا نشعر بهذا
القدر الهائل من العار وكأننا نفعل
شيئًا خاطئًا
ولكنه صعب لأنه صعب هذا
الوقت من العام يقول بومبشتاين  من
المهم أن تسمح لنفسك بالشعور
لأن الحزن يمكن أن يأتي ويذهب ، ولديك
خطة إذا كنت بالخارج أو بالقرب من الآخرين ، هل
هناك مكان يمكننا الذهاب إليه وأخذ
قسط من الراحة
أو إذا كنا بحاجة حقًا إلى
ترك نوع من استراتيجية الخروج  حتى
لا نشعر بأننا محاصرون عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالتقاليد ، فلا بأس من تغييرها
أو تخطيها جميعًا معًا إذا كان من
الصعب فعل شيء
ما بينما تفتقد شخصًا ما ، فلا بأس من
عدم القيام بذلك  وأخيرًا تجد طريقة
لتكريم من تحبهم ، افعل ذلك بطريقة
تشعرها بالأصالة بالنسبة لك ، وقد يعني ذلك
طهي وجبتهم المفضلة أو تشغيل
الموسيقى التي يحبون الاستماع إليها
خلال العطلات أو حتى العمل في
مشروع يكرمهم
ذاكرتهم للصحة دقيقة أنا ماندي
جيثر